this video is sponsored by dragon tamer
have you ever wanted to breed
raise battle or otherwise tame dragons
well now would be the perfect time to
start since dragon tamer is currently
right in the middle of its anniversary
event
where you could be one of hundreds of
players to win an actual dragon figurine
just for playing the free-to-play game
and don't they just look so cool it all
starts when you breed your dragons to
create
new dragons that have characteristics
taken from their parent dragons
that's how breeding works and there are
over 100 different subspecies of dragons
to obtain
and now breeding is more fun than ever
with their all new coloring system which
allows you to select what color you'd
like your dragons to be
then you raise your little dragons from
adorable little babies into
epic adults and then it's time to battle
take them to the global pvp arena where
you'll have to pay attention to what
element your dragon is in order to
counter your opponent or fight alongside
friends in alliance warfare there are
also the forest of spirits or adventure
modes for when you'd like to adventure
alone
and when you grow weary of battle sit
back
decorate your islands and gaze upon your
glorious dragon taming empire
all day or all night so what are you
waiting for
click the link in the description below
to download the game and be the one who
tames the dragons and now on to the
video
hey everyone bandit here last week i was
eating wings at
buffalo wild wings which is my favorite
place to get wings the waiter came up to
our table and asked us what we would
like to drink so i replied diet pepsi of
course and he went off to get our drinks
when he was gone i pulled up my phone
and started checking
i don't know twitter or something when
he returned with the drinks i put my
phone face down on the table because you
know when someone walks up to you and
you want to give them your attention you
do that to be respectful now i was
looking
this way up at him and he was looking
this way down at us and the table
he saw my phone case sitting there which
is a little mock-up of the sheikah slate
and just out of the blue says
man it sucks that we had to wait two
years for some useless gameplay shots
i being the intellectual that i am
didn't realize that he had seen my phone
case laying on the table so i
automatically was thinking
did they announce some sort of chicken
wing mmo that i didn't know about but
then of course i realized that he had
seen my phone case sitting on the table
and it clicked
kind of see i realized that he was
talking about the breath of the wild 2
trailer that we just got last month at
e3 but i didn't understand
what apparently sucked about it so i
just kind of chuckled it off and said
i know right or whatever people say when
they don't actually know what's being
talked about but they don't want to
leave an awkward situation
and that was it the meal went normally
after that but because zelda is
extremely important to me what he said
kind of stuck with me in fact it stuck
with me for hours until much later on
into the evening i asked my brother
about what the waiter had said now
my brother thinks zelda is fine and all
and he understands zelda's impact on
gaming as a whole etc etc but it is
far from his favorite franchise meaning
he sees the franchise and news about the
franchise
from a neutral point of view when i told
him what the waiter had said about the
new trailer
he immediately agreed with the waiter he
said something like
well yeah it was disappointing i mean
the first trailer was dark and
mysterious and there were all these
interesting theories
about it this new trailer feels like it
dropped all of that and that's when
something started to make a
strange kind of sense in the dark
confused mostly empty corners of my mind
see there are ways of telling whether a
new subject or new video game is making
an impact on the internet you can kind
of feel a buzz on social media there
will be lots of posts and threads and
memes made about it and with all the
amazing fan art that we've been getting
on twitter and instagram and stuff like
that i just assumed that yeah people
were loving the new trailer but see
we as content creators on youtube have
an additional way to tell
whether or not something has had an
impact on the internet and it's called
clicks or views if a subject has made an
impact in the heart of your fan base you
could say that subject is
trending and 100 of the time new videos
about
said trending subject will perform
better as more people are more likely to
click
and view said new videos however this
was not the case with the new trailer i
looked around at my own videos and the
videos of some of my zelda content
creating peers and
saw that the views aren't really there
at least when you compare it to the
first trailer of two years ago the buzz
isn't as buzzy as i thought it was going
to be
kind of like what happened when hyrule
warriors age of calamity was released
and please don't take this the wrong way
i'm not trying to
complain about this i'm just trying to
explain it
mostly to myself especially since i
personally was so happy with the new
trailer i mean i had no problems with it
after thinking for a while about what
these two individuals said about the new
trailer and about the lack of buzz that
i've been feeling on youtube i decided
to take it one step further i decided to
see if there was any actual analytical
way to see if this was actually
happening on the internet besides just
word of mouth from a waiter and my
brother
so i got online and went to
trends.google.com and
sure enough it's exactly what i was
worried about
searches for the term breath of the wild
which would include both the original
game and the breath of the wild sequel
or breath of the wild 2
rose 323 in two days on youtube after
the recent trailer dropped last month as
opposed to
searches for breath of the wild rising
625
in two days when the first trailer
dropped in 2019.
the numbers don't lie the first trailer
had nearly twice as much impact on the
internet as the second trailer did and
not only did searches only rise 323
last month but the new momentum of these
searches was completely killed and
returned to normal
after about 12 days had passed in
contrast after the first trailer in 2019
searches didn't return to normal levels
until an entire 30 days passed so to put
this data that i'm talking about into
understandable percentages
according to google's own search data
for the term breath of the wild on
youtube
the first trailer inspired 193 percent
more searches than the second and its
momentum lasted for 250
more days split the difference between
these two percentages and we have a
grand total of the first trailer having
222 percent more impact
overall than the second or in other
words we have a grand total of the
second trailer having a 55
smaller impact than the first so all of
a sudden this lack of a buzz that i was
hearing about and feeling in the dark
confused corners of my mind wasn't just
me being crazy for once
it was actually factually accurate now
right about now you're probably
wondering what the point of all this
impact data is and honestly what the
point of this video is well hold your
horses i'm getting there
the point is why why was the second
trailer's impact
so much lower than the first one i mean
isn't this literally the only thing
we've really been looking forward to for
over two years
now and we finally got it well i have a
hypothesis and it ties
back to what the waiter and my brother
said apparently people were disappointed
by the new trailer actually no joke
unironically while i was scripting
this part of the video and looking at
nintendo's trailers on youtube this
video popped up in my search so i
decided to watch it and guess what this
fellow creator named 247 mr nice guy
said exactly the same thing as my
brother and that waiter said to use some
of the terms he used while the first
trailer in 2019 was great at setting
this darker tone for breath of the wild
2 the second trailer was
underwhelming it was a letdown and by
the way please don't go over to mr nice
guy's video and leave a dislike or bad
comment or anything like that
i just brought his video up to prove my
point that people were disappointed with
the new trailer and he has
just as much right as anybody else to
have an opinion on this the
ultimate question to me now is why are
people disappointed with the trailer
what gives i mean personally i was
freaking out over the new trailer i
loved every second of it i mean just
watch my reaction video on youtube
sure it was a little vague but there
were a lot of definite things that we
got too we definitely know we're going
back to hyrule we definitely know there
are new lands coming
above hyrule i thought it was just vague
enough to be charming and i also really
liked the music so with me coming from
this understanding it was very confusing
to me to realize that not everybody felt
the same way but
honestly do you know why people get
disappointed in things anything
realistically there's only one reason
people get disappointed when
expectations are not
met i talked a little bit about this in
my impromptu video i made earlier this
week about the
new switch oled model and the same
concept applies here to breath of the
wild 2.
there are probably several things to
blame for this being the case such as
you know kovid delaying development last
year for
essentially the entire year and that
leading to people being left to their
own imaginations to run wild with but to
be honest with you
i think that people like me the
theorists are also partially to blame
for the underwhelming nature of the
trailer i mean we are the ones who made
the trailer out to be honestly probably
a lot darker and potentially even a lot
deeper than it actually was
as fans watching these theories
sometimes we can get so
caught up in what could be that we
forget what actually
is and in this case what actually is
isn't much
actually i guess my point with all of
this is that we as an entire fan base
need to get better at
gauging our expectations appropriately
and fairly
and specifically we as theorists and
fans who love to theorize need to become
more careful with our speculations
knowing that we are setting up and
influencing other people's expectations
now this isn't a call to stop theorizing
or stop talking about the game or to
stop watching
theories that's dumb it's just a call to
be a bit more careful with knowing what
is proven and what has not been proven
yet i think we all want breath of the
wild 2 to be
honestly the biggest zelda game yet but
if people are already showing signs of
disappointment and momentum is already
beginning to go the way of age of
calamity it may have a bigger impact on
the fan base than you think
it's what happened when age of calamity
released because everybody was expecting
it to be the actual backstory to the
breath of the wild game that we played
and when that expectation was not met
people
like me were disappointed and therefore
it didn't do as well if we're not
careful the same thing could happen to
breath of the wild too
of course everyone has the right to have
their own opinions on things so if you
watching this were legitimately
disappointed in the trailer there is
nothing wrong with that i would just ask
you to ask yourself
why you were disappointed and really try
to verify whether or not those
reasons are valid but ultimately of
course this is all just what i think
speaking of which what did you guys
think about the new trailer i'm really
curious now did you love it did you hate
it did you watch it and go
meh let me know in the comments below
also thank you so much for watching this
video
essay theoretical discussion slash
warning of mine if you enjoyed it please
leave a like below so that it can get
spread around on youtube for others to
potentially also enjoy and make sure you
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
done so already to stick around for all
the awesome nintendo stuff to come
huge thanks to my bandit crew who are
the reason that i can do
any of this and a big welcome goes out
to faith s
and chris h who have recently joined the
ranks of my elite if you watching are
also interested in joining up and
helping to create
the videos on mass nintendo bandit and
also helping mass nintendo bandit to eat
please feel free to check out that join
button below or follow the links in my
description to my patreon and merch
pages
also down there are the links to my
instagram and twitter so come follow me
on both or either of those for some
spicy takes that's all i've got for this
one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mass
intended bandit looking forward to
seeing you in the next one
and signing out
[Music]
bye